hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
Marvel spider-man on the ps4 is looking
like a contender for the greatest
superhero video game ever with elements
of the Batman Arkham series infamous and
the brilliant spider-man 2 from back in
the ps2 days as more villains and super
villains are announced I thought we
should have a look at them before we
face them on the ps4 we'll be looking at
their skill set their superpowers as
well as the brief origin story for each
character keep in mind many characters
have received countless updates and
their back stories have been reimagined
especially in the films so I decided to
keep to the first version of each
character keeping faithful to the first
iteration where possible let's start
with the man who's got the most air time
over the last year mr. negative aka
Martin Lee this character has been in
the Marvel Universe for about 10 years
now and resembles a sort of Jekyll &
Hyde character
let's break him down mister negatives
origins are harrowing as he was part of
a slave trafficking organization that
crashed on the American shoreline mr.
negative took the name Martin Lee from
one of the dead slaves on board to hide
himself and his wrongdoings only to be
captured by the Maggio gang he suffered
torture and testing upon using various
drugs which cut his psyche into two
after escaping Martin Lee opened soup
kitchens around New York in the hopes of
helping others he eventually found that
his physical touch could heal others in
the comic books Lee saved Eddie Brock
with one touch completely eradicating
his terminal cancer but Lee's negative
emotions took the form of mr. negative
who became an evil trying lot oh and The
Healing Touch he has that becomes a
deadly electrical charge when in this
one in addition to this his touch allows
him to control the thoughts of others
he even controlled spider-man for a
brief period in the comic books mr.
negative controls a huge army he calls
the inner demons who will make up a huge
portion of the grunts we battle in the
game
next on our supervillain hit list is the
Shocker
Herman long time no see hey I'm no
lawyer but Herman Schultz first showed
up in the Marvel Universe back in 1967
he's a bank robber but he wasn't very
good at his job he spent countless years
behind bars whilst there Herman designed
a tool which youth high-frequency waves
to shock open safes and bank vaults he
went on to weaponize this to allow him
to blow holes through walls and punch
his enemies so hard he could stop their
heart on impact going back to his time
in prison for a moment the first time he
used that device he intended to make a
small hole in his cell to escape but he
actually knocked down the entire prison
block he somehow survived and perfected
his design to include a protective suit
and these gauntlets too to control the
waves of power and that's when Herman
renamed himself to the Shocker so we've
already looked at an underworld
mastermind under specialized bank robber
let's dump things down a little with
rhino without a doubt rhino is depicted
as the dumbest villain in spider-man
history
hope you like surprise spider surprise
what is he talking about
Alexei scuse me I can't do that name
Alexei seat Yves [ __ ]
Alexei sitter [ __ ] I'm so sorry for
butchering that was a low-level thug in
the Russian mafia with zero education
and little physical skill to fall back
on Alexey basically just punched people
for a living but what he really wanted
was to bring his family to America but
couldn't have fought to do so so to race
the cash he needed he agreed to be
tested upon by scientists in the hope of
creating an unstoppable right-hand man
for the Mafia
the results were successful as the suit
which was bonded to his skin and
subsequent injections gave him the force
and power of a rhinoceros
the suit was augmented to reflect the
name and now Rhino has arrived
right now hasn't been hugely loyal in
the past first turning on his creators
but eventually he did team up with other
criminals to become a supervillain
supergroup like a boyband physically
he's one of the strongest opponents to
face spider-man but tactically he's a
bit of an idiot he might be portrayed
differently in spider-man ps4 we shall
have to wait and see
[Music]
let's look at the vulture next time no
see back in 1963 Adrian Toomes was
introduced as a brilliant electronic
engineer with a fixation on flying
he was so fixated on achieving this goal
that he never realized his business
partner has scammed him out of his own
company forced out of his own
organization Toombs retreated to his
farm on Staten Island and spent his days
perfecting his electromagnetic flying
harness who once complete the suit also
gave him supervillain strength of course
now he's fixated on revenge upon the
corporate vultures that took his company
Adrian customized his suit to reflect
that hatred and became the vulture he
attempted to kill his old partner only
to be defeated by spider-man and thrown
into prison
sorry old timer your flying days are
over cops will be here soon to gather
you up and put you back in the coop coop
about a roll he's pretty cold his age
makes him a senior citizen but the
vulture suit keeps him on equal footing
with spider-man and his ability to make
and create weapons on the fly can keep
him one step ahead of the webslinger
let's talk about electro not that one
although I have to admit I quite like
this version of electro the original
electro was depicted in the 1960s and
looked like this definitely time for a
redesign in spider-man on ps4 who looks
like this welcome to the park just in
time for the fireworks
electro started life as Max Dylan
another electrical engineer just like
vulture but max didn't have his own mega
corporation no he worked as a low-level
lineman responsible for fixing and
maintaining electrical power lines
little did he know that he had a
mutation in his body which lay dormant
dominant until the day max was hit by
lightning whilst working he suddenly
became capable of controlling electronic
devices kinda like a living electrical
capacitor on top of that he also gained
the ability to generate electricity at
will to fire blasts from his fingertips
to build up his power electro began
stealing technology from Tony Stark
until the day he was finally strong
enough and revealed himself as electro
spider-man has had many run-ins with
electro but struggled to make contact
with max due to the electric shock he'd
suffer in the comics spider-man wore
rubber gloves to defeat electro I dare
say we probably won't be defeating him
like that on the ps4 not all the
villains in Marvel spider-man are male
black cat has also been confirmed
although mainly in DLC form or by the
way this footage is from spider-man web
of Shadows from 2008 black cat first
appeared back in 1979 her real name is
Felicia Hardy the daughter of
world-renowned cat burglar Walter Hardy
well flick decided to follow in her
daddy's footsteps as her black cat
identity suggests she doesn't really
have any supervillain attributes but she
is a highly skilled Acrobat and he's
versed in many forms of martial art
spider-man has forgotten she's just a
regular human in the past if you've ever
played web of shadows in that game it's
possible for Peter to throw cat from the
top of a building and and well well see
for yourself
alternately he can also do this gotcha
I'm getting sidetracked let's crack on
black cat has regularly been a love
interest for Spidey sometimes making her
an ally as well as an enemy really well
guess what I do I still love you
next let's look at scorpion skin we
wrong scorpion our marbled scorpion
first appeared back in 1962 but it's the
1964 iteration that we're going to look
at as that happened within the Spidey
timeline Mackey Garvin was a private
investigator who was hired to follow a
Peter Parker to find out how he took
such great photos of spider-man Peter
avoided him with ease so that didn't
work so instead of letting it go Gargan
took part in an experiment to become the
only creature capable of defeating a
spider let's go
the experiment went perfectly like
always with Mack gaining superhero
levels of speed strength and scope in
esque reflexes he can also walk up walls
or hang from roofs you know just like
spider-man scorpion even has a spider
sense but of course it's scorpion sense
instead all those attributes make him
spider-man's equal in every way on the
battlefield but to give him the edge a
mechanical tail was grafted to his suit
well I hope is his suit a nice interest
scorpion has a fixation on killing
Peters boss J jonah jameson who both
hired him to follow peter around and
convinced him to become the scorpion
let's look at taskmaster as he'll be
testing us throughout the game within
side missions in one scenario spider-man
will need to encase a bomb in webbing
quickly or risk the entire neighborhood
becoming vaporized the other missions
are promised to be completely different
as the taskmaster aka Tony masters has a
very unique skillset known as
photographic reflexes Tony has the
ability to mimic any movement he
witnesses okay that doesn't sound like a
superpower but it really is over time
taskmaster learned every single move
from every single superhero and villain
he obviously couldn't use their
superpowers but by studying them in
different scenarios he was able to
predict their actions and stay one step
ahead of his foes so how the heck do you
fight someone who knows your every move
and reaction
kingpin is yet another supervillain
confirmed in Marvel spider-man
early on in the game will be bringing
kingpin aka Wilson Fisk to justice but
this will only be the beginning kingpin
is a mob overlord and as his name
suggests he's the criminal kingpin if
you remember mr. negative from earlier
it's highly likely the two mob bosses
are in a war hence why kingpin will be
helping spider-man from behind bars back
in 1967 the kingpin emerged after Peter
Parker quit his spider-man persona at
this point kingpin was attempting to
become a legitimate businessman but he
saw the Daily Bugle as the opposition
and decided to silence jonah Jameson
spider-man once again donned his mask to
rescue Jameson but found that the
kingpin wasn't a returned blob he was
actually 350 pounds of muscle
the kingpin went on to defeat spider-man
that day but his obsession with death
traps
like many Bond villains saw spider-man
escape and once again Wilson Fisk was
flushed back down into the criminal
underworld so there we go that's the
first nine supervillains confirmed for
spider-man on the ps4 but many others
such as Harry and Norman Osborn will be
in the game and Doc Ock looks almost
certain to be here too but I don't want
to talk about those without any concrete
evidence so we'll wrap things up here
for episode 1 but rest assured as soon
as more villains and supervillains are
announced I'll come back and we'll break
down their powers their motivations and
their origins I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade it's been good to geek out with
you I'll see you next time
[Music]